66 the professional has compassion for
herself
i got the chance a few years ago to
watch a famous trainer
work with his thoroughbreds i had
imagined that the process would be
something
hardcore like navy seal training to my
surprise the sessions were more like
play
the work was serious as in teaching the
two-year-olds to enter the starting gate
and the horses were definitely learning
but the trainer took pains to make the
schooling feel like fun
when a horse got tired the trainer took
him off the track
if a mount got bored or arrested the
trainer never forced him to continue
or drove him quote unquote through the
pain
he explained a horse is a flight animal
even a stallion if he can will choose
flight over confrontation
picture the most sensitive person you've
ever known a horse is 10 times more
sensitive
a horse is a naked nervous system
particularly a thoroughbred
he's a child a three-year-old big and
fast as he is
is a baby horses understand the whip
but i don't want a racer that runs that
way a horse that loves to run
will beat a horse that's compelled every
day of the week
i want my horses to love the track i
want my exercise riders to have to hold
them back in the morning
because they're so excited to get out
there and run
never train your horse to exhaustion
leave him wanting more